going back on the topic of holidays
though yeah one big part of you know
holiday culture gift giving
oh
how how did rose feel about that i hate
it i [ __ ] it yes yes joey i [ __ ] hate
it it is like i don't i don't normally
feel pressure yeah until i'm until
christmas roll like this time of year
what makes you feel bad about it because
i don't want to
take the time and spend money on
something that in the back of my mind i
might think this person might not even
like it i absolutely despise buying
gifts and
i most of that is because surprise gifts
i especially hate
like what do you mean as in like as it
no no
i don't mind well joey it's funny you
say
that shall we check under your chair
right now because there's a new
lamborghini
but like no like never becomes friend
with mr beast yeah
even though i am but it's like i i hate
uh
like you know i i don't mind giving a
gift to someone if i know that they have
told me oh i really want this thing yeah
or if they're like next to me for
example if you and i were out shopping
and you said oh i really want this thing
then i'll be like and you'll and i know
your birthday is coming up yeah then
i'll buy it for you because i know that
that'll be a gift that you like because
i have confirmation of that yeah but i
hate buying gifts for like you know
like family members or friends that i
haven't seen in a really long time or
maybe i don't even know all that well
personally yeah and being like [ __ ] what
does this person even want right now
what does this person even like how much
money should i spend like how much is
too cheap how much is too expensive and
it's like this mental gymnastics you
have to do yeah to figure out the
perfect gift right i get decision
fatigue buying [ __ ] for myself
like [ __ ] like like multiply that by
like by like [ __ ] 50 or how many
gifts i have to buy for christmas and i
like one one day of christmas shopping
and i'm like pumped out for the week i
barely buy [ __ ] for myself it's like you
hate you hate gift giving but like
doesn't it feel like good when you like
nail a gift you're like it does feel it
does feel good
but it also feels good when you win at a
game of craps right it's like it's a
gamble crap
craps what's that that's a gambling game
what card game
what's crazy don't worry about crafts
we're talking about gift games
no it is a great feeling but like i find
that you only are able to like achieve
that feeling like once every like 50
gifts or something yeah you know that's
because there's only so many gifts where
like it is just the perfect gift where
you just like you where you see their
face lights up and you're just like [ __ ]
yeah yeah that was that was worth it you
know yeah i like giving gifts it's fun
it's funny what if it's a gift that that
you find out that that person didn't
even really like or doesn't even use or
you know it's not the point um
i mean
uh one time meline got me for my
birthday mm-hmm
is mainly listening
okay no elaine got me for my birthday
she got me something i already had oh
really she got me a piece of jojo merch
that i already own right
i didn't mind i was to me it's the
thought that came out
yeah that's all that's all you know all
nonsense you know i can't buy thoughts
can't do anything with them but i i
genuinely appreciated that they'd gotten
something that i mean clearly clearly it
was a good gift because i already bought
it like i
didn't want to do it right yeah yeah i
didn't mind because to me it was like i
don't care that they bought me a gift i
care that they
i cared that they cared to get me a gift
right yeah yeah yeah so if i give you a
gift it means i like you no i get that
but like i'm talking more about like the
practicality standpoint i'm talking
about like to me i feel like that's
social pressure right because i
like like you i wanna i want to make the
other person feel like
i care and i'm thinking about them which
is the entire point i do it but
on the opposite end i it just it it's
[ __ ] terrifying for me because
sometimes you you you see a person
you're just like i have no idea what the
[ __ ] to buy for you but you're like i
care about you but i i have no i want to
buy something like like
if you know you can always default to
one yeah but like you know you can
always default to wine and whatever but
like that's that's that's like the
default gift you know you know that's
like the that's like the adult
equivalent of socks yeah like
i don't want to like i don't want to
just like give all of my friends whiskey
and wine right like
[Applause]
i would like that's why i think like the
the japanese concept of new year's eve
money is so big brain to me yeah right
because in japan we have this thing
called otosidama where adults usually or
parents or grandparents right they give
their younger like family members money
right like basically pocket money but
like on a much bigger scale usually it's
like you know upwards of like a hundred
bucks right depending on the family
but
that just in japan just the thought of i
am giving this money to you because i
care about you and your family that's
that's the gift already but but but
money becomes a gift right so it's
everyone gives money right no no the
gift is that i am thinking about you and
it's the process of giving the money but
everyone gives money right yeah so then
now it becomes a thing of but how many
how much money am i going to get
but it seems expected that you're
getting money yeah and you're you're and
everyone's getting money yeah and you're
a kid you're going to be like how much
money did you get no for me it was like
as a as a kid i would have preferred
money honestly
as a kid yes yeah because you don't get
you don't care about feelings when
you're a kid
you want to eat [ __ ] and play xbox yeah
yeah you don't give a [ __ ] yeah but as
an adult like i can't imagine actually
imagine giving gift giving a fellow
adult to get money as a gift
that's like kind of like an insult
and i know
it's like yo joey i know you're going
through some tough times this is a gift
i know you know you put it into this
i heard about this credit card there
that [ __ ] was whack he's 20 bucks
you know like i don't know i'd be like
oh sick you know like uh here's uh
here's my patreon receipt uh i don't
know to your patreon recently
but you mentioned jerry i hate to have
you like this bro you said your dad gave
you money or something for your birthday
yeah you don't mind that no bro i i'd be
like mom don't give me money no dude
i loved it when my dad gave him i don't
need money bro
he barely gave me money bro i don't i
don't need this from you mom and dad
you've already paid for so much in my
life stop giving me money like give me
give me chocolate or some [ __ ] i don't
know something
i mean like now as an adult yeah now as
an adult i think yeah but as a kid
as a kid i'm not aware of like how much
taxes my dad has to pay your dad all
right pov it's 2021 christmas your dad
comes around he's like joey good kid you
are take this gives you a gives you an
envelope it's got 200 fine australian
dollars in it yeah what are you thinking
how do you feel i'm thinking [ __ ] it you
know how much booze
no
because then what i would do if you
ruined the spirit of christmas then what
i would do is i would put it back in his
face by using that money to buy my dad
like some wine or something right
i don't know man i would i would use
that gift that he has given me to to
give him a gift that i know my dad would
how long
do you spend buying gifts
how long do you spend buying gifts for
christmas barely any uh literally it
does take a while it does take a while
are you the kind of person who buys
gifts like a month or two before the
birthday or the celebration no i mean i
try and do it within a reasonable amount
of time a week or two before right yeah
a week or two before
some people do like [ __ ] months
before well i i don't want to go to a
store i don't i'm not going to store
yeah i refuse yeah i'm going into
interest
amazon is the thing yeah guys come on uh
you know uh
it's yeah i i don't really care that
much but i also care a lot in some
senses i i really want to give a gift
good gift to show my appreciation yeah
somebody being a good friend yeah
actually i want to say thank my homies
the real ones but i would rather know
what exactly it is that you want or at
least you know a general idea of what
you want right rather than just kind of
going i understand that because i like
you know we're doing good for ourselves
i think and it becomes very hard to buy
stuff for people yeah who have money
because you're like well god can just
buy anything he wants joey can buy
anything he wants i mean it comes a
point like not not even if you're like
doing well or not but like you reach a
point in life where a lot of people
around you are adults and people with
adults have disposable income yeah like
okay and then it becomes what's like the
socially acceptable amount to spend on
someone yeah for a gift right yeah
because if you spend too much for
someone then i feel like that's pressure
on the other person i feel like that's
pressure on the other person right
because that you spend a lot of money
for an expensive gift and like i'm like
not not not that i'm like i don't think
they'll appreciate it but i know how i
feel when i when i receive an expensive
gift i'm just like
oh [ __ ] okay now
you know that's like the concept of
money essentially because like some
people who have like they'd have like a
thousand bucks in their entire savings
they some people would blow that all in
in gift giving because right because
that's that's how much it means to them
it's like it doesn't mean anything and
not to like undermine people like that
but you know it does like weirdly yeah
like i completely get what god says
where it's like
if like you know you don't especially
when it's like during a time like
christmas where you're giving each other
gifts right like yeah i if
you know i received something really
expensive from like you know a parent or
something right yeah then i would feel
really bad being like oh man you spent
so much money on this gift while i gave
you a bottle of wine
what if that was a ten thousand dollar
bottle one joe yeah but what if it was
like a twenty dollar bowl of wine you
know
yeah yeah it's it's it's listen unless
the desperate disparity that whatever
this disparity
disparity
oh my god the spelling bee again uh the
disparity unless the disparity is like
a lot i don't think it matters like if
you buy something for 50 bucks and they
buy something for like 150
i mean get over it yeah i mean that that
doesn't matter too much but i mean it i
mean as a uni student i remember that
was like
that was like nine days
you know at least well we did because we
were all broke we agreed on a price like
you wouldn't spend it i like that i like
if you agree on a price i i i like
having systems in place uh when when
like what scares me the most is just no
rules everyone it's a [ __ ]
free-for-all with sydney or aki do you
agree on how much you're spending on
each other no no you just kind of like
so you took sydney could spend 200 and
you could spend like a grand on her
i guess i guess yeah like theoretically
theoretically
something like that where there's been a
big gap in perceived value um no because
i just i don't think we tell each other
how much it was yeah i mean there's
there's there's uh i mean i don't know
when those air max jordans i know how
much they work when they pop
i don't know man how would you feel if i
got you a gift and i was like you know
how expensive that [ __ ] was yeah
like no it wasn't like if i knew the
value of it yeah oh yeah yeah if it's
like something that i i obviously follow
i would know right yeah like so yeah and
then you would you would know what you
paid off i mean
for me in sydney it's just it's
different i guess because i i i know
sydney that's what i'm asking yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
engaged what i i i feel like i can
communicate with sis with sydney like
subconsciously we we know we know we've
we've been with each other there's never
been an an issue with gift giving and
then that you've one of these bought
more than the other no no i i buy aki
and i buy each other gifts all the time
though yeah so it's like not really an
issue when it comes like birthdays or
christmas or anything